eh bien bon soirée loi bonsoir stephen
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
diagonale spécial chocolat du monde
neuvième partie deuxième partie donc on
est rentré dans la deuxième partie du
match
on attendait kasparov à ce qu'ils
reviennent après une préparation sur la
défense berlinoise de chroniques et bien
on a eu raison on a eu raison et en fait
c chronique qui a dévié le premier
puisque kasparov a joué 4 sûr de lui il
en voulait aujourd'hui il était très
motivé mes chroniques à des vies en
premier granit indien premier puisqu'il
vous à 10 h 6 au lieu de juif ou 17 mais
semble-t-il pour cramique peu importe le
nombre de coups ce qui compte c'est
jouer h si ces juifs ou 17 s'est jouée à
ils les jouent dans n'importe quel ordre
ça a l'air bien et bien comme on l'a dit
le plan de crem dick dans ce match il a
trouvé une formule anti garry kasparov
première chose j'échange des dames
deuxième chose je prends la paire de fou
et troisième chose j'attaque l'option b
c'est ce qu'on verra aujourd'hui puisque
c'est le point commun à toutes les
parties jouées par vladimir kramnik eh
bien ils échangent les dames pour la
paire de fouet aux attaques des trois ça
a l'air facile il fait nul sans problème
à chaque fois wes en pologne la même on
a le sentiment qu'ils pouvaient prendre
l'aventage mais semble-t-il non ce
qu'ils ont fait nul semble-t-il ça
serait dans sa stratégie de match c'est
à dire que vladimir kramnik lui ne
cherche plus à marquer deux points ne
cherche plus à jouer les positions
tendue quand c'est nul c nul et tant
mieux
il est très content puisque pour
l'instant rappelons qu'il a un point
d'avancé qu'ils apprennent neuf partis
ils viennent donc 5 4 il a toujours un
point d'avancé devant ça par contre
c'est très léger est ce qu'on va voir un
champion du monde qui gagne une partie
qui a pris le fait que des nuls
est ce que c'est possible c'est possible
ça serait d'ailleurs assez beau un
superbe championnat du monde nul gains
suite 14 nuls et champion du monde ça
serait pas mal en tout cas c'est
énervant
ça serait ça serait frustrant pour les
spectateurs qui m'ont mais nul doute que
de toute façon dans une situation comme
celle là les dernières nul serait quand
même extrêmement combative
oui mais oui parce que kaspar on va
quand même essayer de gagner ne
serait-ce que la dernière partie au
moins ne serait ce que d'un aparté
l'avant-dernière également enfin en tout
cas il ne reste que trois fois les
blancs kasparov pour essayer de
s'imposer
on sait que si chronique ali blanc s'il
veut faire nul ce sera facile pour les
hommes est-ce que mardi kramnik et ont
fait
donc il y en a sur cette stratégie là
est-ce qu'il va aussi jouer pour le nul
facile et mardi au risque d'avoir un an
le nom partie encore alors ça je pense
que c'est des questions qu'on pourra se
poser en fin d'émission stephen puisque
pour l'instant on a quand même des
images à voir on a une partie à regarder
donc dans un premier temps si on peut
envoyer voilà le beau garry kasparov est
en réflexion un peu encore une fois d
abuser car elle kasparov qui croyait
avoir une position avantageuse mes
chroniques non non granic qui comme très
serein que démontre que encore une fois
non non il n'y a pas de problème
chroniqueur et là j'ai tout vu notre
sang couler deux joueurs notre leurs
coûts et là on va assister voilà tout
repenser 3 je propose nul
garry kasparov évidemment très content l
on est très contents son initiative est
passé il a raté son coup igas par aof et
là ils se sont regardés il ya eu des
petites zones yade sympathique
voilà je te regarde travnik je te parle
kasparov
c'était assez sympa ces deux joueurs qui
apparemment s'apprécie quand même c'est
pas c'est pas les les regards et les
discussions qui avaient avec karpov et
c'est pas du tout karpov cochonneries
par exemple ou même karpov et kasparov
effectivement en tout cas la c2 deux
excellents joueurs de très fort j'aurais
effectivement qui s'aiment bien alors
voyons dans cette partie et voyons ce
qui s'est passé donc caspar on revient
ou quatre il a abandonné pendant deux
parties et on se doutait bien que s'il
avait abandonné ce coup c'était pas pour
parce qu'il avait il se donnait perdants
mais parce qu'ils préparaient quelque
chose à montrer chronique il préparait
une nouvelle vague
hualan kasparov et donc effectivement
chronique dans un premier temps ne se
démonte pas et jouent eux cinq cavaliers
f3 qui nécessite donc on ne commande
plus ses coups puisque vous voulez a
déjà commenté au moins trois fois oui
tout à fait
fouquet cinq cavaliers f6 c'est la
berlinoise ich bin ein berliner à
l'appareil que la première et la
troisième partie pour l'instant petit
rock qui récupère les 44 tours des
quatre essais lors de coups qu'elle
dessine signifie processes dépensé 6 des
promotions nous enseigne cavalière 5
d'un programme d'un poids dames roi
prend qu'elle et ses 3 kasparov ne
change pas la chronique dans toutes les
deux parties qui ont précédé avait joué
son fou s'est vite sur la caisse 17 avec
une idée toute particulière de passer
son roi à gauche c'est à dire sur les
cases par ici oui hélas ils innovent ils
innovent joue le coup le classique parce
qu'il se doutait que kasparov avait
sûrement préparé quelque chose donc le
premier
il pose un petit problème à kasparov qui
change tout le coup il faut d'abord
acheter
il prend l'initiative et effectivement
après h6 c'est un tout autre plan c'est
une toute autre
enfin pas complètement différente mais
pas pareil non plus puisque après deux
tours d un échec est bien le roi noir
nova plus ans s'est vite mais on évite
alors on a l'impression que quoi que si
c'est du coup il ne sert à rien puisque
cette idée de secousses et d'empêcher le
cavalier blanc de venir sur la case g5
et d'attaquer paris vii mais maintenant
que le roi est en 1 8
il protège déjà la quinzaine est donc
peut-être kasparov essayer de démontrer
que le cauchy c'est une perte de temps
alors je ne pense pas stéphane
puisqu'une autre idée h6 c'est quand
même de pouvoir développer le fou s'est
vite sur la case aussi ce sens qu'il y
ait cavaliers g5 rappelons quand même
que dans cette position-là avantages des
noirs c'est la paire de fou en
compensation les blondes une avance de
développement et en plus un avantage de
structure puisqu'il on capture contre 3
à droite de l'échiquier voilà les quatre
pions de kasparov
ah ça c'est le seul avantage qu'on avait
déjà signalé contre trois les parties
précédentes
voilà c'est important tout ça donc on
vous leur montre et voilà donc en fait
kasparov ici à un avantage davantage de
structures chronique à la paire de fou
c'est tout l'enjeu de cette partie
voilà et là alors différents soucis
kasparov ne joue pas le plan avec
détroit
oui puisque il avait mis b3 et le fou en
b2 pour protéger son pion cei mais non
et cette fois il change il joue h3 alors
h3c le coup qu'on lui avait reproché
quand même dans cette première partie du
match
c'est vrai ça ressemble à une perte de
temps oui mais ici effectivement c'est
beaucoup plus sensée à noter que les
joueurs jouent très vite pour l'instant
oui
h3 et sur quoi comme nick lui alors là
c'est superbe
il joue les coups à 7 à 5 je m'en fous
kasparov ajouté coup moi je regarde pas
ce que tu fais je fais toujours pareil
japon et la sauce voilà vous avez tous
les ingrédients je mélange et ça marche
mais je veux toujours h 6 à 5 fu 17
éventuellement et toujours pareil
facile donc garry kasparov ici change de
planches ou mail font un f4 alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils vont f4 et bien
en principe j'ai l'impression que ce fou
va de l'autre côté que le roi noir c'est
à dire que là le fou vise indirectement
il a un oeil sur l'option c7 et quand le
roi aller de l'autre côté ce fou à les
enlever devant la soupe au lait en b2 il
se mettait là pour avoir un oeil sur le
pion g7 que le roi ne pouvait pas
défendre
donc en fait le fou c'est un peu comment
dire
sorte de contre-pied ou un dribble ouais
c'est un dingue de l'autre côté énorme
c'est bien le dribble c'est bien c'est
un dribble krainik ici je vous faut
aussi aussi salorges mal à noter les
blogs trafic est un peu différent comme
deux autres pièces ouais c'est un peu
différent la fosse mais il avait déjà
joué ou six oui oui
d'ailleurs c'était très bien c'était
lors de la première partie ça s'était
très bien passé sans douleur est ici
kasparov surprend quand même puisqu'il
joue assez rapidement je crois le coup
j'ai 4 way première surprise sa force le
caïd kramnik déjà à battre en retraite
donc le cavalier s'en va en fait c'est
la seule case et pas les voir on
s'énerve et pousse ses pions
kasparov qui est des quatre maintenant
la calle d4 et l'idée c'est de prendre
le faut si c'est évidemment l'idée
vladimir je te pique ton fou je te pique
temps fou comme ça t'as plus la paire de
fulham et moi je conserve mon avantage
de structures j'aurai toujours quatre
contre trois et j'aurai toujours
davantage au développement donc a priori
je suis content mais la dîmière lui ça
me gêne pas du tout il avait prévu
vladimir il choqué et des cinq îles mais
s interroger sur la centrale y attaquent
le fou de kasparov la bible en prennent
des 5 mai reprend du fou et si on prend
le fou des seuils des 5 va être très
bien défendu par deux pions nous allons
l'analyser cedar entre cavaliers
propension des cinq ici je crois que
l'idée c'est qu'après pions prend on
attaque effectivement de pièces en
attaque le fouet f4 et le cas et c'est 3
le coût des blancs c'est donc très
logiquement food et 2 et maintenant je
crois qu'on peut prendre ces trois mêmes
stéphane on peut éventuellement prendre
un c3 et après fou prend obtenir une
position très très correct simplement ça
a l'air très difficile pour les banques
d'améliorer cette position on va jouer
tous ces cinq échanger toutes les tours
sur la colonne des avec nul assez
probable donc kasparov en fait pour
exploiter son avantage de structure
estime qu'il lui faut garder un cavalier
et non pas permettre tous les échanges
ont caprica et d4 et d5 et bien qu'à
sports jean cavaillès ce2 ont l'art et
c'est subtil qu'il joue vite et on sent
que il est content de son coup oui parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'ils disent est
une préparation même passion que c'est
une petite préparation de kasparov c'est
un des coups qu'il avait envisagé
donc il a l'air tranquille mais kramnik
se démonte pas on voit que kramnik aussi
l'a envisagé et sécher un peu mais
qu'est ce que c'est quand même un coup
attention c'est un coup responsable
puisqu'il ya possibilité ici pour cramer
ne te prendre le deuxième fois voilà
mais là ça fait deux cavaliers qui
serait extrêmement bien placé il y
aurait un piège ici il ya puisque là le
seul coup maintenant pour empêcher
le fou d'être pris avec un de pioncer de
jeu recettes et damien petit piège alors
recettes c'est pas le seul coup c'est un
mauvais coup effectivement puisque il y
à une réfutation direct cavaliers des
profs ou oui il faut reprendre du pied
et maintenant la fameuse fourchette
diagonale tacler g6 allégé 6 avec
attaque du roi et de la tour à schmitt
qui gagnent donc la tour voilà tout à
fait donc ici ce n'est pas bon ce n'est
pas possible et garry kasparov le sait a
plaidé mercredi qu' aussi et après kelly
ce2 ici il faut changer d'option pour
chronique il doit jouer le coup fous ces
cinq coups qu'elle joue vite et qui est
surprenant dans cette situation puisse
même pas mal non on sort ses pièces
c'est pas mal mais attention parce que
l'idée de chroniques pour l'instant tout
au long de ces partis c'était mes pièces
sont prêts développer car je ne sors
plus je les laisse wells ont elles sont
très bien placés dès le départ il
échange d'idées là il change d'idée
pourquoi pas parce que l'on peut donc
peut se dire ça rame ni pour le kung fu
et sa note il il a peur de rien donc
cavalier 30 fou puis on prend si on
prend hélas après ces cas pas mal parce
que la hat semble fort c'est qu'un
symbole fort puisque ça enlève la casse
des cinq aux cavaliers et le gros
problème c'est que quel point f4 père en
ligne et perd tout de suite puisque
après cavaliers prend kelly prend et
bien toujours évidemment alors celui-ci
leroy montant à 7 pour défendre son pion
aux six la fourchette la fourchette sur
le roi monde af 7 6 le roi 09 c'est
maintenant la tour ici la tour en d1 qui
monte sur la case 17 avec un échec
dévastateur la femme s'est fait manger
et surtout en fuite
le coût qui est envisageable il ya deux
lectures il prend 1,6 tout simplement
car les prend 1,6 attaques toutes les
pièces
alors la voie la ceni les magic ce
cavalier stéphane quoi elle peut lire il
attaque luz et 5
il attaque également la torah fuite
c'est important ils attaquent l'option
g7 c'est pas mal non plus et il attaque
l'option c7 qui font une fourchette donc
quadruples menace même trame unique ne
peut pas l'appareil voilà tout à fait
donc là c'est pour ça que kramnik ne
prend pas le fou de kasparov
après ces quatre chroniques voisine
planète son cavalier sur cette case
affreuse qui allait rater trois en tête
mais on va voir que cramique un peu plus
loin ç'a l'air horrible puisqu'ils s'y
cassera tout naturellement b3 et là
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit un cavalier
en b6 minable calaire minable il al'air
minam puisqu'il est complètement dominé
par les pions blancs tout à fait dominer
tout à fait dominer par les pions blancs
il faut bien le dire
chronique avait l'air quand même très
mal diatonique au stand qui est passé
nous voir aux analyses
pendant le direct est ici ils voyaient
kasparov beaucoup mieux - classement et
en fait on va voir que craint de voir
plus loin que tout le monde craint dit
quoique loin que tony kosten en tout cas
tony lot à 4 et c'est pas mal c'est que
c'est un peu la même idée facilité sous
enseigne d'ailleurs c'est de jouer à 4
d'ailleurs il faut jouer maintenant
puisque si on ne joue pas maintenant les
blancs eux mêmes vont jouer à 4 il
annoncera difficile à lui ont même
aurait envisagé de le jouer et donc là
on est bien dans le plan de chroniques
pour l'instant il ya déjà échangé les
dames il a pris la peur de fou mais il a
rendu mais maintenant il va commencer à
attaquer les battre c'est là qu'on voit
que le après le coup suivant de kasparov
fou des deux foulées de coûts que
kasparov avis et voilà ce qu'il veut
jouer fou c'est rois et maîtres sont
fous sur une bonne case tout à fait fou
des deux la chronique a bien joué il a
joué le coup qu'on avait prévu donc
c'est un bon coup bref c'est pas mal et
c'est là c'est là qu'on voit que
lecavalier b6 était bien placé puisque
même si 14 n'avait pas joué ou des deux
le cavalier empêche une tour de fer en
échec sur la case 17 tout à fait sa
valise important est important dans le
contrôle c'était sq les empêche donc les
infiltrations blanche à noter évidemment
que le coup b4 on va le jouer mais n'est
pas un coup n'est pas un bon coup pour
les blancs
ça a l'air fort comme ça il s'avère fort
est tout à fait prête pour ça repousse
le fou simplement le fou s'en va voilà
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
d'options aux prises il ya le penser car
très pions b4 qui sont reprises par le
folk à manier oui mais surtout ces cinq
courses est justifiée c'est le cavalier
noir qui saute sur la glace des cinq qui
est merveilleuse
alors là le cabinet noir il n'est pas
près de bouger il n'est pas près de
bouger il est superbe
donc ici le coupé 4 qui a l'air
prometteur ne l'est en fait pas du tout
évidemment et kasparov l'a compris si
t'es sport je vous fous ces trois coups
assez logique
c'est un coût de développement avant
tout voilà et là maintenant on attend
quand même que kasparov essaie de
pousser son pion fc le glandon et il va
falloir jouer roger 2 et poussé le pion
f pour essayer d'attaquer mais la
chronique quand je voi très jolis mots
tout simples tours hd 8 et on voit que
ça va permettre soit d'obtenir la
colonne a pour les noirs soit la colonne
des oui alors pourquoi est ce que les
blancs ne peuvent pas tenir les deux
colonnes en même temps tout simplement
parce que la menace c'est ici qu'on
prend b3 une promotion crombez 3 et
après on échange nos portes quel tour ce
qui fait que les blancs ont une colonne
soit là à soi la dea et les noirs
l'autre voilà et alors qu'est ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'à une grosse différence
c'est que les noirs sur la colonne à il
entre sur ces cases là qui sont clés
et sur la colonne des eas entre sur
cette case là qui est très importante
alors que le nord ne pénètre pas alors
que les blancs ils n'ont que la casa
cette rencontre est tout à fait c'est la
seule et quel sport va évidemment
essayer de l'exploiter mais ici à priori
les doigts en plus de casse de rentrer
donc forcément dès qu'une colonne de la
souris qui mettront ils ont le choix
alors que les blancs ont pas le choix
donc ici ça nous pousse à trouver le
plan des blancs qui est d'échanger
toutes les tours mais malheureusement
caracas prof n'a pas trouvé de solution
il y en avait probablement pas d'entorse
pandémie tour en 1 8 et là donc les
noirs ont la colonne des les plans ne
peuvent plus de mètres de tour sur le
petit solal non mais la colonne allez
roger deux joué par kasparov qui dit et
bien dans cette position j'ai pas de
problème tour des 3 ça me fait rien
c'est une case qui ne sert à rien moi je
pousse je joue f4 et puis après je
jouais f5 et puis je fais valoir ma
majorité quatre contre trois sur quoi
comique il y avait la caisse détroit
quand même je l'apprends j'ai la torre
est très bien placé ici parce que elle
vise le fou ces trois si le foot bouge
et bien c'est le plan b 3 qui visé et
puis ça a un oeil sur le pion h300 pêche
laurent blanc ne monte et voilà et en
plus si les blancs jouent le pion
maintenant f2f 4 on peut jouer le
coutour trois cas l'air quand même
embêtant mais là c maximum sur les huit
cases de la colonne de la largesse et
bien il y en a six
utilisable ouais c est quand même pas
mal cette tour est superbe c'est pas mal
joué de la part de chroniques kasparov
trouve un plan pour aller changer cette
tendance et sa chance mais la chance a
fait le tour c'est un leader kasparov
s'est tour ces deux pour ses 2es tour d2
et tours d2 pour échanger les données
changent tellement leurs craintes avant
tout à fait mais non chronique dit non
il joue entre il joue très bien la
chronique il joue plus on prend non jugé
cinq agresseurs
c'était inattendu ça c'était inattendu
une idée c'est d'empêcher le cavalier
blanc sur la case de deux maintenant que
le fou est protégé peut-être kasparov
menacé de jouer cavalier quatre chats
sans la tour et ensuite ramenant le roi
vers le centre
crown et qui s'immola un plein dangereux
se structurent g5 c'est effectivement
très responsable c'est un coût qui ont
déjà et ensuite quand les blancs
joueront f4 et bien tout de suite ils
ont une majorité valoriser on le dit
valoriser c'est à dire qu'elle n'aura
plus à avancer leur a déjà fait 7 mais
d'un autre côté ce coup j'ai scène qui
est pas mal parce que ça empêche un
petit handicap d'être stable et donc ça
affaiblit un petit peu le pion aux 5
tout à fait ça c'est très important pour
la suite de la partie le pion aux cinq
maintenant et on mangeait et à manger
parce qu'il n'est pas
difficile à soutenir par le pion à f2 on
a longtemps pensé que vous à 3 était une
possibilité pour kramnik avec l'idée qui
a aidé cette équipe et ces cinq
mercredis 4 nuls à jauger 5
qu'est-ce que je tour ces deux quand
même c'est son plan ouais et maintenant
c'est l'heure d'empêcher tour d2 non on
joue plus on prend b3 une première
tranche comprend bien avoir mené 3-1 et
que les 17 17
évidemment maintenant si la tour fait
d'abord échangé les pions en belgique à
la d17 puisque les blancs menacé de
prendre au blanc 4 on dit qu'une
variante qui était dangereuse entendu en
tout cas maintenant ce qui est sûr c'est
que sur tours d2 eh bien on va échanger
les tours boum
le foot doit quitter son poste et des
forêts reprendre et le pion hussein ait
pu défendre le pion aux 5 voilà ça y est
il y est le cahier dé cette attaque et
le prendre pour des deux n'est pas
possible donc ici tour d2 pas possible
garry kasparov ennuyé puisqu'on ne voit
pas comment il peut améliorer ses pièces
d'art et d'essai si on voit pas ce qu'il
a ouvert la colonne a enfin l'arrêt
colonna mais la ville a pris les perdre
du temps pour ça il a déjoué tour cn
tour ces deux et maintenant la colonne
ait ouvert il faut qu'ils reviennent sur
le colonat donc en fait il a perdu
beaucoup de temps il ya perdu au moins
303 comme la tour qui ne servent à rien
et ici le jeu tour à 2 il revient et on
voit quand même son idée qui a l'air
assez forte
il va venir en 1 8 on suppose qu'il peut
envisager de voter 4 comme stéphane il
possible chasser le centre est ensuite
rentré sur la case à cette attaque et
tous les lions voilà c'est le ramassage
scolaire ici on va prendre tous les
enfants qui traînent tout ce qui traîne
tour à deux mais cros à lorient
serviable ça c'est un croisé ce qu'on
s'attendait à un coût possible de crown
ixina cette position le coup b5 qui
avait l'air fort ça avait l'air très
fort stéphane avec une pointe c'est que
bon déjà première pointe on menace de
jouer b4 en main et regard des 3 voilà
le fou ces trois d'en bouger et le métro
est en prise par la tour voilà autre
menace possible on prend on sait qu'a t
on fait qu'ils aient b6 bon ça ça arrive
dans certains cas également très logique
pour les blancs c'est de jouer eux mêmes
b3 b4 chassant le fou ouais
s'il fait si la largeur puisque si les
cinq ans jouent ces cinq après est
l'ennemi du nord sont complètement de
vie s'est étouffée étouffé étouffé
complet mais il ya une pointe d contre
twente on prend ces trois un service de
qualité qui est possible et après
cavaliers pro tour fous ces cinq
professions b4 voilà le câble et ne peut
pas bouger ça un attaquant le fond ce
qui serait idéal
attention parce que fout prof le week
end attaque trois éléments oui lequel
ces trois l'option c4 et le pion aux
cinq essais quand ça fait beaucoup plus
ancien est attaqué par le cavalier et
donc après un coup comme cadeau
autre champion français 4 où on joue car
les premiers 50 au procès qu'elle était
plus jolie il y avait une belle variante
on va vous la montrer parce que on est
quand même là pour s'amuser c'est vrai
c'est tour à 7
garry kasparov dit je vais être inquiété
pions oui sur quoi on joue je trouve c3
c3 et après tout reprend ces sept on se
dit la tour revient et bien non il ya
ces deux ces deux menaces dame
donc on peut pas prendre le cavalier sur
ce compte qui va dire le roi leur holt
non je crois bien huit attaques la tour
où vient 8 c'est pareil attaque la tour
non c'est encore plus fort puisque la
tour doit quitter la tacc droit et ne
peut pas venir en d1 obligé la promotion
puisqu'elle serait prise par le pian
double menace donc était classé 1 donc
il faut prendre ce pion c6 et la kbc 5
et ça y est on s'aperçoit qu'on ne peut
plus rentable on sait qui va les faire
dormir tranquillement coup d'après donc
ça c'est une variante possible à ce que
kramnik pas rater ça c'était oui alors
effectivement je pense pas de tram ni
qu'il ait raté mais toujours est il
qu'après tour à 2 garry kasparov
il a préféré plutôt que de jouer des
saintes qui rentrait dans les
complications complexe non mais c'est le
cas de le dire
il a préféré que fawcett tranquille
chronique avait l'air décontracté à
noter quand même qu'il était toujours
vivante on pouvait lire oui il faut sept
tours 1-7 joué par kasparov qui n'avait
pas vraiment le choix kasparov qui
commence est sous pression pour quoi et
bien parce que le quai 17 qui était très
mal placée en bas 6 l et revenir sur les
4 c 5 et attaquer attaquer b3 mais
menacé de venir en quatre bref ça
devenait catastrophique n'est ce pas au
jeu tour à cet essai 5 quand même ça ça
que vers 3 pour le nascar avait lieu
quatre probablement et devant la menace
qu'a lieu 4 kasparov a eu plus ou moins
un peu peur il n'a pas trop le choix il
faut jouer il a joué s de f3 de f3 pour
empêcher qu'ils allaient aux 4 et la
chronique à ramasser l'opinion et en v3
facile à glisser un petit point qu'on va
montrer qu'en même temps prendre 17 la
chronique drôle très joli coup cavaler
c1 est là l'idée c'est que si le cas
lebron clavier évidemment le foot en
prise avec mais comme kasparov aurait pu
jouer éventuellement lapointe suivante
tout reprend pions pour procter avec
l'idée que si les noirs prennent le
cavalier et bien maintenant font des
quatre ici récupère le fawcett qui est
cloué et en plus se retrouvera donc dans
une finale avec tours fou contre tours
cavaliers où effectivement on va tout
ramassé puisque après tout reprend 7 on
commence par clic est aussi depuis ses 6
bref le parcours de la tour est
prédéterminée très fort c'est horrible
mais il ya une contrepoids et
heureusement heureusement heureusement
pour ramener
via cavalia quatre échecs klf4 échec et
là le roi bouge oui par exemple en f1 et
si miraculeux parce que lecavalier up
soit sur la classe g 6 la seule et oui
qui protège le fou voilà les noirs en
une pièce de plus donc ici ce n'est pas
acceptable pour gagner et c'est joli
quand même effectivement après
chélifiens il ne peut pas jouer pour
prononcer cette île est obligé de jouer
quel point cavaliers ce qu'il fait sur
quoi chronique tout reprend ses droits
et là coup de théâtre alors qu'on
pensait que les noirs commencent à être
mieux et bien cramique propose mieux oui
c'est assez surprenant c'est les images
qu'on a vu au début et crame dit que les
kasparov évidemment s'est jeté sur la
main de chroniques proprement oui parce
qu'on a l'impression que le noir peuvent
jouer leur rôle au gain on peut
peut-être faire une simulation aussi
puisque nous avons la place des joueurs
oui je vais faire cramique donc voilà je
joue tout reprend ses 3es jeux proposent
nul voila c'est exactement ça garry
kasparov s'est proprement jeté sur la
main de la dîmière kramnik est tout
simplement accepter la nulle oui parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on peut jouer
pour le gain avec les noirs
oui même si on passait voyez tout à fait
on va montrer la variante on va quand
même entre on va repasser par montrer
rapidement la vente qui aurait pu suivre
donc là cavalier 2 à leurs forces et
qu'avait lieu de salaire force effective
bien car il est attaqué on prend le pion
c4 les noirs les blancs prennent le pion
c7 est maintenant les noirs on va le
montrer en un pion passé c'est le cauroy
8 pourrait vite à leur fort j'y vais en
passer trois des huit qui va chasser la
tour de la colonne c est ensuite on en a
le pion c'est à avancer il y aura le
pion aux cinq faible oui ça fait de
faiblesse pour les blancs et en principe
on dit qu'il ya des bonnes chances de
gain cantonniers de faiblesse alors que
s'est il passé pourquoi alors bon
évidemment c'est pas forcément si simple
il ya beaucoup de possibilités pour
trame dick beaucoup pour kasparov aussi
cramique objectivement sa situation dans
le match se dit nul c'est pas mal oui
c'est pas mal c'est vrai de toute façon
c'est bien pour kramnik on aurait aimé
en voir quand même quelques coups de
plus pour voir pourquoi c'était nul
parce qu'il faut toujours la question on
n'est pas au niveau des champions mais
bon ils savent évidemment que
l'opposition est nul pour horizon pas
besoin de le démontrer alors statu quo
je vais dire une loi quand même un peu
ras le bol des nuls quoi alors ça
faut quand même le dire puisque
maintenant c'est surtout des nuls très
très ennuyeuse ses fans puisque au début
on a quand même eu des nuls de combat en
un lieu où on a été nuls fantastique
fantastic route est à deux doigts de
gagner voilà voilà
avec des retournements de situation pour
ce que kasparov et mieux et ainsi de
suite voilà là c'est linéaire c'est
moche mais c'est chiant alors on n'est
pas très contents effectivement on
espère un peu plus de punch et de punch
de la part de gaza sans ça va venir tôt
ou tard c'est obligé parce que kasparov
d'oeuvre à un moment donné et c'est
gagner sinon il perd le match donc de
toutes façons il est sous pression
kasparov
il n'a pas le choix il va falloir qu'il
trouve quelque chose qui prennent des
risques et qui s'engagent dans des voies
qui donneront des chances aux deux camps
sûrement d'ailleurs kasparov est dos au
mur stéphane je crois qu'on peut le dire
et donc on va bientôt assister à du
grand spectacle moi je pense que dans la
prochaine d'ailleurs chronique qui
allaient blanc va peut-être quand même
essayer d'aller chercher une galerie qui
movie tch c'est son deuxième prénom même
façon on a vu
que kramnik avec les blancs comme il est
très fort il a failli battre kasparov
plusieurs fois mais mes casseroles un
peu refroidi hier puisque avec les noirs
il a sorti une grosse préparation dans
laquelle il était peut-être mieux même
c'est sûr j'étais mieux puisqu'il a
gagné un pion et donc ça va peut-être
refroidir à munich on peut peut-être
dresser un bilan du week-end pour
terminer et bien qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans ces deux partis les deux fois
on peut dire que c'est kasparov qui a
pris l'initiative dans l'ouverture
la première parce qu'il a planté une
préparation et la deuxième parce qu'il a
menacé d'en planter une nouvelle qui l'a
forcé cramer qui a dévié le premier donc
ça c'est important pour l'instant on
assista qu'en mai dans la galerie qui
est en train de remonter
oui et en dehors du terrain il prend le
terrain c'est rising c'est maintenant de
plus en plus les options de kramnik dans
le jeu tôt ou tard on a l'impression que
kramnik va être obligé de mettre son
pied sur un endroit min voilà c'est très
probable donc en tout cas on sent
qu'avec est en train de revenir
et là évidemment ça devient très très
chaud puisque à kremnica peut-être c'est
peut-être essoufflé dans ce début de
match c'est possible sur quoi le foot
kasparov va sortir de sa cage va bondir
et ça va commencer à chauffer pour le
jeune challenger exactement donc on vous
donne rendez-vous à mardi pour la suite
de ce championnat du monde